عوضا عن تناول الكبسه بالارز المشبع
بالدهون مع زملائه في مقر العمل بات
السعوديه عاصمه الشمريه توجه الى مطعم
قريب لتناول وجبه صحيه ويعد المطعم الذي
يقدم هذا النوع من الوجبات بعشرات
الموظفين اثناء السراحه الغذاء في منتصف
النهار لما جربت الاكل يوم يومين ثلاثه
ايام حسيتي فرق من ناحيه التخمه العمل بعد
الدوام ايام ما كان في فاست فود كبسات
خمور والعمل بعد البريك بيكون اصعب
بعد ما جربت الاكل الصحي ارجع للدوام
طبيعي بالعكس ارجع فيه انيرجي اكثر
فعجبتني الفكره مع الايام حسيت ان وزني
قاعد يخف
لم يكن من السهل قبل سنوات قليله تناول
وجبه صحيه قليله الدسم خارج المنزل لكن
مطاعم الاكل الصحي باتت منتشره الان بل
اجبرت مطاعم الوجبات السريعه على تقديم
وجبات للرشاقه في توجه جديد في عدد من
البلدان في المنطقه مع زياده الوعي لدى
الافراد باسباب ومخاطر البدانه التي يتوقع
ان يعاني منها اكثر من نصف سكان العالم
بحلول عام 2005
بتحس ان الناس يعني خلاص غلبت تتجه على
الاشياء الصحيه اذا مش بس للاكل يعني في
اشياء صحيه كتير ناس بلش
موضوع الاكل
المطاعم العاديه
ويتوقع الاتحاد العالمي للبدانه في الاطلس
الذي اصدره لعام 2023
ان واحدا وخمسين في المئه من سكان العالم
اي ما يتجاوز اربعه مليارات نسمه سيعانون
من البدانه او زياده الوزن خلال الاثنى
عشر عاما المقبله وجاء في التقرير ان
معدلات البدانه اخذه في الارتفاع بسرعه
خصوصا بين الاطفال وفي الدول منخفضه الدخل
وافادت التقرير بان البدانه بين الاطفال
قد تتجاوز مثلي مستويات عام 2020 لتصل الى
208 ملايين فتى ومئه وخمسه وسبعين مليون
فتاه بحلول عام 2035
قال الاتحاد العالمي للبدانه ان التكلفه
التي سيتحملها المجتمع لبدانه ستتجاوز
اربعه تريليونات دولار سنويا بحلول عام
2035 اي ما يعادل ثلاثه في المئه من
الناتج المحلي الاجمالي العالمي ومع ذلك
قال القائمون على التقرير انهم لا يلومون
الافراد
لكنهم يدعون الى التركيز على العوامل
المجتمعيه
والبيئيه
والبيولوجيه لهذه الظروف